when I was the editor of reason in the
early 70s we got a article that was
submitted that proposed a method of
converting the world to libertarianism
and that was by going door-to-door and
distributing to every household a copy
of ala shrug we reject to the article
and I don't I never felt we did made the
wrong decision but it just is an example
of the kind of impact that Randy has had
and continues to have on many many
people r and is I think a very valuable
resource in the movement for people who
take Liberty seriously we knew that if
we did anything with rent or about rad
there was egg shells that we would have
had to tread very lightly on and we did
have an idea and i think if i recall
who's Bob to you I think maybe more
Tibor than any who thought that we
should do a special issue devoted tyne
rad and in planning that issue among the
other letters that we sent out I sent a
letter to Iran asking her if she telling
her what her plan was and asking her if
she would care do we'd love to have her
contribute a piece and we never got a
response which really was a surprise at
that point in the in the history because
she was notorious for not responding to
people we also sent a letter to her and
her publishers about our plan to use my
treatment of her likeness that was from
a photo they had been published and we
were aware there were copyright issues
we never got an answer and then I wrote
and said that we didn't hear again we
would consider that they had no
objection to are using the photo they
didn't respond properly otherwise we did
our own take based on that photo this is
the cover that we use and the date of
the issue it was november 1970
three special issue reason this was a
sellout we had to do a reprinting of
this issue and we offered a free copy of
this issue for new subscribers that led
to the one of the more interesting sagas
with I'm and and reason because we got a
letter directed to us from Iran's
intellectual property lawyers in New
York they demanded that we cease and
desist from continuing to offer the back
issue they demanded that we turn over
all existing inventories of our back
issue over to advance lawyers for their
destruction and they said we didn't
comply they were in a suit that would
take appropriate legal action so I was a
young rambunctious lawyer and practicing
with a law firm called Kindle mandersohn
and midsize law firm in Los Angeles the
time doing litigation work and I had
done some defamation actions and had
some familiar with a subject area and
they had cited the New York's of a right
statute that made it illegal to use
somebody's name or likeness for
commercial purposes without their
written consent so the issue was
basically a First Amendment issue
whether we had a First Amendment right
to publish the likeness or information
about a person who's in the public eye a
public figure without their written
consent and we thought we had a pretty
good case legally under the New York
statute and what's more it seemed kind
of quirky for Iran to take this position
about confiscating our property that we
had generated so I made a telephone call
to the Lord that sent a letter from this
new york law firm and I introduced
myself and as I was responding the
letter and we engage on a basically
cordial conversation during which I
mentioned that I was surprised to get
the letter that we really didn't feel
that we were the kind of target that
Iran should want to go after I
understand there may be some hostile
feelings that you might have
about some of the articles and features
who have run before but we really this
this the issue they were promoting was
very favorable up in the subjective very
positive response and if I mean if I men
didn't want to help us the idea that you
would go after us didn't seem to be
appropriate desirable or even
understandable and I said one of the
things i'd like to do i said no if you
want to follow lawsuit i said i would
look forward very much to taking on
rants deposition because i'd like to ask
her what the moral basis that she feels
she has to confiscate our work product i
said by the way one other thing I have
to tell you I said you know up until now
the most interesting name I've ever seen
for any case in the anvil American legal
system was USA vs Richard M Nixon I said
this would topic Rand versus recent my
regret was that I said too much I feel
on the phone because we never heard from
them again they let us alone I never got
my deposition so I learned some days you
don't want to spell it all out too soon